first of all you guys made a film during
copen which is insane
what made you say yes and second of all
were you nervous leaving your house
well i said yes because i was very
excited uh
that doug lyman was making a film and
and was interested in me for it
and then i read the first 90 pages of
the
script and it was just wrong
and truthful and made me laugh and also
made me so
sad at times and there was just so much
in it uh it made me really
it just made me excited to become a part
of it so i jumped on board
um thinking that there was only going to
be another 30 pages coming because
usually films are about 120 pages it
turned out to me and this one was 180.
so so it was definitely an exhilarating
adventure
um and then was i scared to leave my
house i wasn't scared to leave my house
i was scared to go to harrods
because we filmed in harrods at at night
but in order to make it we had to arrive
just as the store was closing so that
part
i i wouldn't have made that choice in my
personal life to go to some place so
public so that part
did scare me right yourself to at all
yeah i mean i you know i just was
thrilled about the whole thing you know
just excited to to make the film and and
i thought that the um
you know i read that first 90 pages and
again i
i felt the same thing that it was you
know i was like how are they going to
wrap this up you know say you know
and you know it wasn't quite halfway but
the um
but i just think it was a great team of
people to work with
on this film i think that uh i wasn't
worried about it because
as i arrived there i just knew that we
were working with people who were being
extremely careful
and diligent about social distancing
about masking about
um we were getting everybody was getting
tested regularly and so
there was a sense that um everybody was
going to be
to be safe and that and everybody was
taking it all incredibly
um and seriously and it was the one
thing that was allowing us
to sort of slowly get back to to work
and do the thing
that we love doing and so um so all of
that was
um was was fantastic and it was great to
make a film that reflects the times that
we're in but also has
right yeah
yeah and and your character is bringing
you know the wine the wine is so
relatable it signifies
so much i mean what is that thing that
keeps you going what's that coping
mechanism you need in your life to get
through
all of it oh i can't tell you that
that is way too big um
um i i have noticed i'm eating a lot
more cheese these days
nice um uh but no i think i
you know what you know what i'm doing
now that i didn't do
in the beginning in the beginning i felt
all this pressure to say that i was fine
and um and i was kind of trying to
intellectualize my my way out of it i i
was like look at everything that you
have you have so many things going for
you got food on the table your mortgage
is paid for you've got a roof over your
heads you don't get a right to complain
so many people have it so much worse
than you and that is all true
and valid and it's okay if i have a bad
day and it's okay if i'm scared and it's
okay if i'm anxious
and yes so i think the way that i'm
letting myself get through that is
just by admitting when i'm struggling
like everybody else
i love that i love that you're
self-chewing
yeah i mean i i don't i don't have
anything to
to add in a way chocolate or working out
anything
oh you know yeah but yeah working out
you know has been very
it's been very good you know the um uh
just to keep your
sort of just sanity you know that's
that's like the whole thing and just i
just think it's that connection it's the
connection with family
even if you can't see family but you are
connected to them
the phone zoom whatever and just um you
know just and friends
and just the enriching that those
connections and those personal contacts
you know which i think for me
because you know prior to all of this
you know my life was just
at such a clip you know that i didn't
even
you know it's like i wasn't i didn't
even take the time to look around most
of the time i just was moving from one
next and and i realized that it's that
old ferris bueller thing you know you've
got to stop and look around once in a
while
you know because it seems to me so that
that
that understanding that for myself has
been a really
a really strong part of uh of this and a
really strong part of my own kind of
i suppose my overall health
you